Air Miles are awesome, they can be used to
score free flights, hotel stays and if you’re
really lucky, the scorn and hatred of everyone
you come in contact with who has to pay full
price when they travel.
The king of all virtually free travelers is
one David Phillips, a civil engineer who teaches
at the University of California, Davis.
David came to the attention of the wider media
when he managed to convert about 12,150 cups
of Healthy Choice chocolate pudding into over
a million Air Miles.
Ever since, David and his entire family have
been travelling the world for next to nothing.
So how did he do it?
Well, first we need to explain the kind of
man David Phillips is; he’s the kind of
guy who reads every inch of the small print
on things.
The kind of guy who learned to count cards
just so he’d never get ripped off in a casino.
In fact, Phillips stated that he could have
probably been a pro card player if it wasn’t
for the cigarette smoke.
Yes, this guy- according to him- could have
been a millionaire card player, but he enjoyed
fresh air more than the musky stink of success.
His most famous endevour was back in 1999
when he saw that Healthy Choice was having
a promotion on their frozen entrées section.
The offer was as follows: for every 10 bar
codes of their product a person sent in, they’d
be awarded 500 Air Miles.
However, the company had an early bird stipulation
that people who redeemed the offer within
the first month of the competition would receive
double that, meaning a person could potentially
receive 1000 Air Miles for buying just 10
of their entrées.
Upon catching wind of the deal, David scoured
his local supermarkets to see which, if any
products offered the best potential return.
After some legwork, he found what he was looking
for- a discount grocery chain that was selling
individual chocolate pudding cups for 25 cents
each.
This meant that for a measly $2.50, he could
get 1000 Air Miles.
Realising the amazing return he was potentially
able to receive, David set out to hit every
store in the chain in one day and buy up every
single Healthy Choice pudding they had.
Now, you’re probably thinking a guy walking
into several stores and asking to purchase
all the Healthy Choice pudding they possessed,
even in the back of the store, would arouse
suspicion; and if anyone cottoned on to what
he was doing, they’d try to get in on it
too, because, why wouldn’t they?
David apparently had the same concern and
while buying the pudding, he told people he
was doing it because he was stocking up for
Y2K, which was just around the corner.
All in all, David spent just over $3000 on
pudding, which may seem like a lot, until
you realise the total dollar value of the
miles he was set to receive was in excess
of $150,000.
However, before that, he actually had to send
off all of the bar codes.
According to David, his wife got blisters
from peeling off hundreds of stickers and
his kids and co-workers grew physically sick
of the sheer amount of chocolate paste he
was forcing on them.
Further, it began to look doubtful they’d
be able to peel off all the barcodes in time
to qualify for the early bird part of the
promotion.
This is when David had another idea- why did
he need to have his wife and children suffer
when he could get others to do the leg work
for him?
David approached the local Salvation Army
with an offer; if they gave him a bunch of
volunteers to peel off all the bar codes on
his pudding, he’d donate the pudding to
them.
But here’s the beautiful part, doing this
counted as a considerable charitable donation,
which let David claim just over $800 back
in tax deductions at the end of they year.
But the benefits of David’s scheme didn’t
end there.
After sending off the bar codes and getting
back his 1,280,000 miles, (he got a few more
than just from the pudding because he also
bought some soup at 90 cents a can before
he realised that was the sucker’s method),
he now officially had over a million miles
in his frequent flyer accounts, which automatically
gave him lifelong access to something called
the “American Airlines AAdvantage Gold club”
giving him and his family a number of awesome
flying related perks for the rest of their
lives.
But we haven’t even got to the best part
yet.
David will likely never run out of Air Miles
because he’s still earning miles at about
5 times faster than he’s spending them,
despite traveling quite often, thanks to various
frequent flyer incentive programs he keeps
an eye out for and exploits just like the
pudding scheme.
Today, he has over 4 million miles in his
various accounts and has flown to over 20
countries and taken numerous vacations in
the meantime.
In the end, for a one time cost of a little
over $3000 (or less if you subtract the tax
deduction), and a few other similar deals
he’s taken advantage of to bolster his numbers,
David never has to pay for a flight in his
life ever again.
Genius.